avant le reste réparti
les gars
on se sait
ces conditions par les boues
tous à fond chacun de notre côté donc
c'est ça qui est beau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est plus
celle ci va commencer ils sont 56 trimer
qui vont live tout le week-end et
normalement ça devrait se tenir dimanche
soir à minuit bonsoir bienvenue sur le
11e et 2022 mon premier est également le
dernier donc le make up for the world
s'est pas tu n'as pas l'air de rose
ricard pour les 200 femmes 2 euros
combien
de 5000 euros quelqu'un va venir taper
ici sur la mailloche tu es le premier
d'accord cette petite mailloches 3 2 1
s'est bâtie aux savons pas combien ça
c'est 1 700 l'histoire 34 tout le monde
va passer donc on va faire un classement
totalité ajouter directement au
classement je le montrerai de temps aux
acheteurs des leaders pour l'instant
enchanté là il ya un nouveau jeu qui
marche super bien auprès des vieux meurt
en gros ils ont lancé une chaîne twitch
qui s'appelle bi-place spécialement pour
l'événement et en gros les peurs peuvent
jouer à pokémon édition verfeuil il ya
deux modes différents il ya le mode
démocratique tout le monde peut voter
pour diriger le personnage faire des
actions pendant les combats de pokémon
et c est un mode anarchique et c'est
vraiment le bordel ils vont pas y
arriver les gars il va y arriver à
garder regarde le personnage lego
on est dans la bière dit là on est dans
la merde vous le dis
tu vas pas te payer
le mec me laisse tout seul je suis pas
streamer bon je sais pas quoi dire je
suis là je suis pas un chaud sont les
gars je suis en chaussettes j'ai oublié
mes chaussures à l'hôtel
ok citron pour moi
qu'on rattrape des activités quitte les
plus pour le moment aux events et le zip
laisse en fait c'est un espèce de
tableaux de canevas digitales sur lequel
n'importe quel viewer n'importe quelle
personne peut acheter des pixels sous
forme de dons évidemment pour ensuite
créer une oeuvre dans un grand carré et
donc là il ya toutes les communautés qui
s'activent pour écrire le nom de leurs
streamer préféré ou pour mettre une
petite anecdote digital et à la fin ça
donne un espèce de tableau que tout le
monde pourra télécharger qui sera un
énorme soutien de ceux ci voilà là on a
l'oeil là on touche plus là on touche
plus mais il est bien là il est bien
wade déjà des dessins de pour abaisser
ces moments un moment ait perdu ils ont
attaqué et yahoo le night wa
l égard sincèrement vous êtes trop forte
[ __ ] merci beaucoup ça fait tellement
intense je le prends en photo ça c'est
émouvant tellement un plaisir d'être
d'avoir une communauté comme ça il y
avait déjà eu ça y est quelques mois sur
edit des centaines de milliers de
français avaient participé avec le
streamer cas métaux que fait une oeuvre
typiquement française au milieu de plein
d'autres pays
quand même que ménez et gameiro et les
bons on va les payer
m
thébaux
je fais tapis actuellement avec
avec ceux ci
qu'es tu n'es plus ni moins une gatling
allen grossièrement
oui ça vient juste planter des petits
fils
de laine dedans et du coup je reproduis
demos de minto ce faire un tapis qu'on
m'offrira après hamilton je fais quoi
moi je reste notre coeur mais je sais
pas de base comme tu veux c'est jamais
ça saoule dur mais le live ici on est
libre ici c'est the event puisque tu
merci de m'accueillir vous savez les
sportifs dont je peux faire de la pub on
est un peuple non mon album est
disponible alors tout à fait robertson
donc là là si j'ai bien compris ils vont
ils vont analyser les gens qui ont été
bannis de la chaîne de domingo et ils
vont juger le niveau de badens fait donc
c'est pour ça qu'ils sont jugés tout je
découvre le concept avez vous eu flow me
dis rien je suis pas du tout au courant
donc je crois que c'est ça voilà ta
tolérance à la commune pour cela tu
dirais alors ton slip de tolérance moi
j'ai été moi c'est la découpe parfois tu
vas voir ya des bavures un mec qui dit
genre
t'es pas très beaux boubous berman qui
va se faire le problème ce n'est que moi
je suis d'accord tout au long du
week-end ils vont aller sur les streams
uns et des autres pour faire des
activités tous ensemble mais en général
il ya qu un seul moment traditionnel ils
sont tous réunis sur le même jeu c'est
le vendredi soir à 21h sur fall guys un
objectif peut-être le dernier survivant
à
mais jean corti je perde il ya quelques
mois j'habite plongée club aura des
moments très bon moment
oui oui c'est égal
voire
[Musique]
et
emilie qu'arrive la mieux qu'un livre
ça va être plus beaux traits divine et
bientôt le million d'euros bientôt le
million d'euros attention
m
oh
un million 21h30
faut savoir qu'ils ont réussi à récolter
le million d'euros l'année dernière à
23h là il est seulement 21h30 ça veut
dire qu'ils sont en avance et à chaque
fois qu'ils sont en avance ce vendredi
soir en général ça annonce qu'en fin du
week-end il ya sûrement un record qu'ils
aient battu sa de long beach à chaque
fois et j'ose pas imaginer ben j'imagine
qu'on va pas s'arrêter là et ça va être
que du bonheur du bonheur en barre c'est
complètement
c'est avec hyper vite cette fois trois
heures
mignon des rangs
ce sont des gens
taper dessus
on va rigoler est sympa on va être léger
c'est un sari
un peu comment comment aurais je me
faire détruire ça fait un nom en plus
d'un an qui fait de la boxe avec
végétaux limit
line qu stand des stratégies il essaie
de trouver des moyens c'est
littéralement un boss de dark souls
kevin qc en train d'affronter madame et
monsieur on est en dessous des fusées
volent les regarder alalala links qui a
littéralement limite n qui est repoussé
dans le coin 3 4 5 ou 6 7 kg
le fair play avant tout alpha vainqueur
il est trop fort des fois je prends des
troubles en confiance je le voyais un
peu sourit j allais et ils m'ont envoyé
deux rencontres tout le monde se fait
plaisir
devant comme derrière la caméra donc
donc content pour l'instant je suis
impression dans la suite moi je suis
mort de fatigue mais c'était
contre moi je connaissais pas bien tout
cet univers c'est flou qui suit depuis
le début le zylo that even donc le sec
alors qu'aol a tué la pratique la
lumière le bruit moi je vais dormir les
gars première journée de ouf
mesdames et messieurs bonjour bienvenue
en direct de montpellier il est
quasiment 10 heures on a de la vence est
parfois trop tard cette façon d'aimer
coincé c'était une super forme j'ai
lancé life et plus à 8 heures du match
quoi et là il ya eu plus de 1500 euros
dont cdd fou malade là aujourd'hui
on est passés les peintres aucun times
et merci pour les 150 bull 150 places je
vais éviter de laisser votre avis
vous voulez qu'on lui fasse juste une
barbe moi c'est parfait bon ok on
continue ans
le but c'est de faire un truc écologique
aussi à une ville écolo du coup on a
essayé de faire
cette année si le public et les brewers
qui ont eu la possibilité par vote de
choisir quelles associations
environnementales allait être soutenue
au cours de ce jeudi 26 on a cinq qui
ont été a retenu il ya six shepherd et
si cleaners notamment pour la protection
des océans ensuite il ya la ligue de
protection pour les oiseaux wwf et enfin
l'entreprise time for deux planètes qui
lutte contre les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre mais eux ne récupèreront
pâtes dont ils sont juste venus pour la
visibilité de l'événement pour pouvoir
parler au grand public de leur action le
choix de l'environnement pour les events
est la marque d'une connexion directe
avec notre génération avec des gens qui
sont très mobilisés sur ce sujet et ça
me paraît absolument incontournables
comme thème point the event toi y'a pas
trop à prendre parti pour l'écologie on
voit bien que c'est un petit peu la
merde partout et c'est compliqué ça ne
te concerne toutes et tous et on va dire
qu'on va un peu dans le mur donc pas
comme si on avait le choix de régler de
régler ce problème si régler le problème
est le bon terme donc moi je pense que
c'est une très belle chose de défendre
cette cause là c'est même une cause qui
est plutôt facile à défendre et j'espère
que les quatre à ceux qui vont recevoir
l'argent et des syndications qui sont
présentés frotta qu'on espère derrière
aussi nul j'ai envie de dire aussi les
jeunes quelque part parce qu'on ya
beaucoup de jeunes dans nos communes
nous aussi on est jeune et j'espère
qu'ils feront
avec cet argent qu'on va leur apporter
la juste dernièrement il ya quelques
stream qui sont venus sur le plateau du
z event pour faire un jdr un jeu de rôle
sur qu'est ce que ces quatre bénévoles
pour sea shepherd qu'est ce que c'est
que de protéger les océans il ya aussi
la mia la présidente de sea shepherd
france qui est là et qui viendra leur
dire s'ils ont correctement réussi à
représenter cette réalité alors
malheureusement
tu endommagent un peu le zodiaque on est
là pour ça et des balais et on ne sait
pas où est le harponneur que nous
recherchons c'est pareil pour le moment
c'est problématique nous notre stratégie
ça a été justement d'aller sur place
d'empêcher les baleines d'être harponner
parce qu'en fait le plein de de
commandeur de condamnations diplomatique
dans des dents dans des forums
internationaux ça ne sert strictement à
rien donc l'objectif tellement sauver
physiquement les baleines et la france
et 3000 km de côtes donc en fait on est
la deuxième puissance maritime au monde
je fais pas ça regardez le seul pays à
être présent dans tous les océans de la
planète l'apport financier que ça va
avoir
ça peut vraiment changer la donne pour
passer par contre puisque ça fait des
années qu'on doit pouvoir se financer un
bateau pour intervenir en mer sur les
côtes françaises on à 3000 km de co
un semi rigide et deux petits coqs à lui
si tu veux donc on est vraiment vous
équiper en termes de moyens maritimes
france qu'en france vraiment vu l'enjeu
nos besoins de manière maritime plus
importants et
et là l'argent qui va être collectés
avec les event ça va nous permettre
d'accéder à ça
chris jackson au plus près de l'action
le combat de catch show était pourtant
bien parti jo se fait maîtrisé chose se
fait défoncer c'est la victoire du
mexique a eu lieu
mexique à 4 dégâts
bon chocolat chocolat c'est à
ventabren nature de la merde et dont le
seuil de 10 euros des mains bâle merci
merci infiniment
[Applaudissements]
millions pour le trap est bonne sans
préavis
c'est à tous attends quoi cagnotte perso
30 2010 nextag
5000 euros tu sais ta peau du cou mec
c'est le top
mais parce que c'est incroyable je me
tâte ou le pseudo du toc donateurs de
toute ma cagnotte
hélas alors inox inox voilà l'étude
montre et on croit et c'est beau et
c'est incroyable
et ça c'est important d'être là ça part
en master sur cinder les jo chaque année
il ya une émission qui cartonne le
samedi soir ces questions pour un
streamer animé par étoiles l'année
dernière il avait présenté avec samuel
etienne et cette année il ya un invité
spécial c'est alain chabat donc ça va
être une édition spéciale burger quiz et
ça commence dans quelques instants c'est
rigolo de rencontrer alain chabat ou un
point que je le vois et quel honneur de
recevoir quelqu'un comme ça évidemment
en respect pour l'événement alors qu'on
a un énorme respect pour lui c'est très
drôle de me dire que j'ai commencé ça
dans mon salon aujourd'hui alain chabat
dit on est tellement contents d'être là
complètement irréaliste
les eu et on se déplace comme ça et me
suivent
ce cas
bonjour à tous on est aux i even 2022 et
cette phrase est totalement vrai on va
faire un question pour un streamer
burger édition avec alain chabat
merci de me recevoir merci de
m'accueillir je suis très flatté d'être
là pour ce magnifique événement donc là
je vais vraiment faire tout ce que je
peux pour ne pas vous [ __ ] la soirée
j'ai essayé de rapporter des sous bois
voilà c'est tout quel et l'altitude du
kilimandjaro à 100 m frères
5916 m
quel sport est mise à l'honneur dans le
film les crevettes pas hésité dès 2019
le water polo
tu n'as pas le droit de me répondre
avant la fin des cinq questions l
affaire des cinq questions tu dois
essayer de poser les cinq réponses dans
l'ordre j'ai près ça te déconcentre pas
trop si jean fils cette tête de cheval
tu penses que tu chose combien des mains
je vais enlever cette tête de cheval et
tu me dis si c'est toujours moi dessous
tu aimes bien joué au nitrite cheminon
tuchan me répondre que oui tu chômage et
enfin un vrai ou faux lgbt est
l'acronyme de la grosse [ __ ] à toto
quand tu veux non je 11 oui c'est bien
vous non tout est faux
cette organisation là et elle est
tellement joyeuse et généreuse
le marteau
bateau
on a quelqu'un 6
664 c'était c'était un premier essai
qu'est ce que tu dis ce qui se passe
non mais t'inquiète inquiète inquiète
inquiète ya pas de souci
il a dansé pour le deuxième coup mais le
katla cette machine au lendemain du tout
là tu t'exposes et 7 ans
monsieur alain chabat c'était un plaisir
merci beaucoup je te laisse la mecque
étoiles
les 221 moi je pense on va finir ça y
est d'éteindre la plupart dernière donc
ils sont passés en moins de lui mais il
ya quand même un karaoké qui est en
train de de commencer et ça risque de
durer une partie de la nuit
tout le monde à l'assaut
aulas
les causes de
la mort
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
bah là on est dimanche exténués mais
mais on tient le coup parce que c'est le
dernier jour il va y avoir le dernier
rush de vin et l'autre et a très hâte de
voir comment ça va se passer ça se voit
pas sur mon visage parce que j'ai l'air
exténué mais je suis je suis très
impatient d'être
au trésor 15 ans nés dimanche étant sur
le point de dépasser les trois millions
d'euros
lui
j'ai absolument pas du tout est nickel
voilà ça qu'on veut voir remonter les
portes on vous avait fait péter les trop
mignon
j'aime beaucoup être accueilli comme
travail faut savoir qu'à ce chiffre qui
l'ont pas encore ajouté le nombre total
de ventes de t-shirts qui rapporte
chaque année beaucoup d'argent donc la
cagnotte dois encore beaucoup monté
vous ne vous mérite pas trouvé les mots
merci beaucoup
en amont de ce g20 il ya eu beaucoup de
critiques sur les réseaux sociaux
particulièrement sur twitter de la part
de personnes qui aiment des streamer des
youtuber qui était présent aux éditions
précédentes avec des très grosses
communautés qui mobilisait beaucoup mais
qui ne sont pas venus cette fois ci et
donc il ya plein de gens qui disaient
que cette édition ne serait pas un
succès c'est pour ça que énormément ce
qu'ils meurent ici répète en stream ou
en interview que ça va être un flop que
c'est un flan pour malgré tous les
paliers qui sont dépassés au fur et à
mesure est donc là pour beaucoup ce
streamer c'est une sorte de pied de nez
à toutes ces critiques qui ont eu lieu
les dernières semaines en amont de
l'événement en fait je pense que j ai
même ça aussi comme l'était à pain
sans prétention je veux dire quelle
communauté 6 et 27 minutes esi event
c'est pas la communauté de serre à tort
moi c'est vraiment la communauté de tous
ceux qui sont là
et en effet il n'est pas attaché à un
nom précis c'est une erreur de penser ça
je pense qu'à vraiment une sens du
collectif ils l'ont trouvée là et c'est
très fort et ça dépasse le fait de
suivre telle ou telle personne tout au
long de l'année je pense que ça c'est
plus beau message de rassemblement de
solidarité et de partage qu'on puisse
véhiculer donc
c'est pour moi
vous pouvez en acheter
j'ai horreur de me répéter le
le match de catch qui arrive local ch
évidemment c'est du spectacle on s'est
entraîné à tomber très vite on s'est
entraîné à prendre des trucs très vite
et où es tu
bon ce sera pas parfait c'est évident
mais on va tout donner pour que ce soit
voilà un vrai show un vrai show de cash
deux équipes complètes qui vont
s'affronter donc je vous le disais sur
ce ring tout de suite on va accueillir
la première d'entre elles mesdames et
messieurs c'est l'équipe montazer
[Musique]
accueillir la deuxième équipe de ce
combat l'équipe elle aspire
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs place au combat et
ados caster à l'andi agence et du taux
d'équipement kazakh s'est tendue s'est
tendu
je ne sais pas comment de réagir un
forçat
oh
ici l'agression pandore posture un petit
peu difficile pour l'agent michael la
duel et speedy il faut les encourager
dans leur chasse aux
bien que le coach sébastien loeb il
contredit le sommeil est totalement ce
n'est qu'au dessus attention qu'est ce
qui se passe est une autre
[Applaudissements]
l'arbitrage en selle catch bien sûr
cette conversation merci pour
l'opportunité
à bosser pendant deux bonnes semaines
deux bonnes semaines de boulot et ouais
c'était dur parce qu'il fallait lever
des appréhensions et ou machin mais
parce qu'il a des techniques comme qui
font très peur moi j'étais dedans
j'étais content vraiment incroyable tu
étais au bord tu vois les tu vois les
trucs tu es là des fois tu as mal pour
eux mais en fait sont même pas m'excuser
mais qui a pris lui a lu un petit coup
mais s'accroît alors vraiment c'est
impressionnant bonjour vraiment j'étais
à 1 m mais ma - des fois je touchais
c'est franchement
nous on se donne mais les gens derrière
leur écran aussi ils se donnent ils sont
comme nous ils ont des cernes c'est le
week end on se donne tous à fond chacun
de notre côté donc c'est ça c'est ça qui
est beau on apprend que vous chaque don
est utile
les
jeux
jean florent s'imposer
[Applaudissements]
voilà comme vous l'avez entendent faire
attendre le début du iii e reich il
reste que quelques heures avant la fin
de l'événement tous les streamer ont
appelé leurs communautés à faire un
maximum de dons l'année dernière en
seulement quelques heures il avait levé
plusieurs millions d'euros c'est un
moment très important pour cette
cagnotte
thibault également 20 euros truc bug
alors c'est le rush final charleville un
2e but c'est terrible je sais et je n'ai
pas su continuer
merci pour les bambins pour les uns ce
n'est pas croyable merci beaucoup
envoyé au web et au passé l'autre
millions
très vite ils scandé dix millions
d'euros c'est complètement balle
féline de faire les 10 millions d'euros
récoltés ils vont dépasser dans quelques
instants le record de la ligue 1
mais
j'ai passé mon meilleur moment musique
est bonne ça
et ça c'est ça c'est de la belle
ambiance monde si l'on partage des
effluves de la sueur à m'élancer test
est excellent c'est un super six et 21
et que j'ai besoin de ça chaque année
mais parce que c'est la réalité ça
chaque année il n'y a pas de mots
l'événement était in fine on a fait
mieux que l'année dernière où l'année
dernière s'étaient déjà impossible à
battre et j'ai je suis juste aux anges
vous pouvez pas aimer meilleur finish en
les jetant à avoir une gueule et alors
des frac tfc du bonheur cette année ça
fait plein d'activités partout avec les
copains on avait touché un moment de
loof merci zerator dit
aucun mot
je sais pas de quoi tu y es letterman
rocha non j'ai trouvé redistribue fait
plaisir mais à ces moments si ma mère
c'est peut-être la meilleure semaine que
j'ai pu vivre l'ambiance était ou et je
suis trop content est bon même si je
suis mort j'ai plus de moi et que je me
rends tu m'as quand je vais rentrer
demain quand je vais faire soit passé je
verrai la gauche y a personne à droite
personne que je vais bouger que la
personne mais bon je serai que toujours
actif et peut-être de gagner bas c'était
vraiment magnifique merci à vous tous et
on n'existe pas sans les gens se
révoltent 10 passant les gens leur corps
existe pas sur les gens
c'est pas parce qu'il ya des bouffes qui
ramène d alain chabat ici qu'il faut
oublier les gens club
je voudrais remercier toute la clique
politique française depuis les 30
dernières années pour a fait des
décisions et des conséquences
désastreuses sur l'environnement qui ont
recommencé à percer jour de nos jours ce
qui a sensibilisé des millions personnes
qui maintenant regarde le z event pour
donner de l'argent caritative mans à des
associations qui s'occupent de la
planète c'est beau quelque part c'est
beau la vraie sensibilisation par la
demande ça c'est le vrai capitalisme on
les aime c'était n'importe quoi ce truc
c'était n'importe quoi les locaux rouge
tard tu dois te laisse ici on arrête des
gens avec antoine daniel mais lui
tellement de dons de gens motivés qui
sont surpassés honnêtement je suis
épuisé sa dose
mais [ __ ] c'était un week-end de ma
diva bon c'était incroyable regardez je
suis là celui-là
c'est le moment pas rigolo on doit tous
rangés pour angers dire aux copains
c'est toujours le petit moment de la
mélancolie mais on utilise faire de ce
qu'on a pu faire et fier de la
communauté nous sommes bénis d'avoir la
chance de participer à un tel événement
en fait et je suis fier également
d'avoir pu aider à ma façon et à mon
échelle aussi
oser dire est surtout pour une pose
quand même
si importante technologie qui nous
touche tous ces jeunes
et même c'est qu'ils sont pas niés qui
ça touche qu'une
histoire celle afin d y est bonne si
cette forme là est
pour quelque chose de peut-être plus
confidentielles et je sais que dans le
milieu du streaming il ya plein d'autres
personnes qui ont envie de créer des
événements caritatifs collectif et du
coup il y aura plein de nouvelles choses
de nouvelles formes masi et 26 cette
formule aurait été quelque chose
extrêmement important un rendez-vous
vraiment unique du coup non c'est
vraiment incroyable ceci est bonne c'est
aussi le hurlement d'une génération sur
un thème le climat hurlements qui va
devoir être entendu parce qu'il s'agit
pas juste de donner de l'argent je pense
que tous les donateurs avaient
conscience que ce n'est pas en faisant
des dons qu'on va sauver le problème il
ya maintenant il ya besoin d'un sursaut
les jeunes ont montré qu'ils étaient
prêts à le faire qu'il se défasse
mobiliser sa scission d'avec avait
encore des doutes ma pensée claire et et
nous on est fier d'être au diapason de
cette génération est de relier son
hurlement avec cet événement reste les
normes mais voilà mais ces tissus heures
en fait c'était sûr